-Elle est née un 8 mars,
un signe du destin, diront certains.
Mon invitée nous a fait voir
les barbecues sous un autre jour,
et c'est sa force.
Elle arrive à imposer ses thèmes
dans le débat public
vaille que vaille.
Générique
...
Bonjour, Sandrine Rousseau.
-Bonjour.
-Votre première télévision,
je crois, vous l'avez faite
en tant que romancière.
Autrice d'un roman policier,
c'était en 2007,
pour un polar intitulé
"Epluchures à la lilloise".
-C'est un homme qui est retrouvé
mort une partie du torse arrachée,
enfin épluchée.
Et cet homme est entouré
de femmes dans sa vie,
donc il faut savoir
qui a eu cette idée
saugrenue de l'éplucher.
-Il y a 4 ans, exacerbée
par un chef, elle se venge la nuit
avec des mots.
-J'ai commencé à écrire
quand la coupe a été trop pleine.
C'est une caricature
d'un de mes chefs.
Le soir, c'était un peu
comme une poupée vaudou :
je lui plantais des aiguilles.
Rires
-Qui a eu l'idée saugrenue
d'éplucher cet homme,
selon vous, Sandrine Rousseau ?
-Ca me fait rire
parce que cet extrait
a mis encore...
-Oui, ça tourne en boucle
sur internet, c'est drôle.
-Oui, et puis
ça crée une panique morale
alors que c'est un livre
complètement humoristique.
Il faut le lire...
Rien n'est sérieux là-dedans.
Mais c'est la panique morale,
dès que je parle.
Mais j'ai épluché personne.
-Ce qui m'intéresse
dans cette archive,
derrière le second degré
que vous aviez adopté dans ce roman,
c'est qu'il y a déjà le féminisme
et la radicalité.
-Et l'écologie.
Ce qui n'est pas dit dans l'extrait,
c'est qu'il y a un fond écologique
dans ce roman policier.
-Féminisme,
radicalité et écologie,
c'était déjà en vous ?
-C'est vraiment marrant parce que
dans les critiques qu'on me fait,
il y a beaucoup le fait
que je sois devenue opportuniste
alors que si vous reprenez
mes déclarations depuis 30 ans,
je n'ai pas bougé d'un iota,
c'est même
peut-être un sujet.
-Quand on vous entend parler
de poupée vaudou,
on a le sentiment
que l'écriture a été pour vous
un exutoire à une colère.
La colère,
vous l'assumez dans votre façon
de faire de la politique.
Pour vous, la politique
est une sorte d'exutoire ?
-Non, c'est pas un exutoire,
en l'occurrence, la politique,
c'est plus une manière
de gérer aussi
une forme d'angoisse sur le monde
dans lequel nous sommes.
Je n'aime pas le monde
dans lequel nous sommes,
qui ne prend aucun soin...
-C'est pas pour évacuer
un trop-plein ?
-Non, mais la colère, je l'utilise
dans les émotions de la politique,
parce que je trouve que ce qui a tué
la politique ces dernières années,
c'est le fait qu'on ait face
à nous des gestionnaires
froids qui ont des tableaux Excel
et qui nous disent :
"Il faut augmenter ça,
diminuer ça..."
Je pense que ça doit être dit
et que ça doit être un élément
du débat politique.
Sinon, il y a que la haine
comme émotion dans le débat.
-A l'époque de cette archive,
vous n'étiez pas
encore vraiment engagée
en politique.
Vos débuts datent de 2009.
Vous vous présentez sur la liste
aux européennes de EELV,
puis aux régionales, vous devenez
ensuite porte-parole de EELV.
Mais vous n'avez pas
la même façon
de faire de la politique
qu'aujourd'hui.
Comment vous la décririez,
cette Sandrine Rousseau d'avant ?
-J'endossais beaucoup plus
les codes de la politique.
Le fond était quand même le même,
j'ai pas bougé là-dessus,
mais j'endossais plus les codes
de la politique.
-Plus conformiste ?
-Oui,
j'étais plus conformiste
et je me comportais plus
de la manière dont on attend
que quelqu'un
se comporte en politique,
et ça, je l'ai fait voler en éclats
à partir du moment où il y a eu
cette affaire Baupin,
où je me suis dit :
"Ce qu'on attend de nous
ne sera jamais convenable."
Notre place en politique
n'est jamais gagnée,
ni notre place dans la société.
"Donc allez,
on va tout faire péter,
"au moins dans le discours
et dans les codes."
-Dans votre vie, il y a un avant
et un après 2016.
Le 8 mars de cette année-là,
le député écologiste Denis Baupin
a posté un message sur les réseaux
sociaux avec une photo de lui
accompagné d'autres députés
qui aveint tous du rouge à lèvres,
avec un message contre les violences
faites eux femmes.
Vous avez vu cela,
ça vous a mis hors de vous.
Avec trois autres femmes,
vous avez déposé plainte contre lui
pour une raison simple.
On va écouter votre témoignage
de l'époque.
-J'étais à une tribune,
j'organisais une réunion,
et à un moment, j'ai voulu aller
aux toilettes,
et dans le couloir, Denis Baupin
m'a calée contre un mur
et a cherché à m'embrasser de force.
Je me revendique féministe
comme celles
qui justement osent parler.
J'ai la possibilité de parler,
je le fais pour toutes les femmes
qui n'en ont pas la possibilité.
Et pourtant, même moi,
je ne l'ai pas dit.
Même moi.
-Alors vous, féministe,
vous n'avez pas osé, sur le coup,
dénoncer cette agression sexuelle.
Cette prise de conscience,
ça a déclenché beaucoup de choses ?
-Déjà, je l'avais dit
à la direction d'EELV.
-En interne.
-Oui.
En fait, ça a été
une prise de conscience
vraiment de plein de choses.
Déjà, de la violence à laquelle
on s'exposait quand on parlait,
ce que je n'avais pas anticipé,
et puis de l'ampleur du phénomène.
Là, on est un an avant MeToo.
-Un peu plus d'un an avant.
-Et à ce moment-là,
quand l'affaire Baupin sort,
qu'on est, Hélène Debost,
Isabelle Attard,
Annie Lahmer et moi,
quand on descend dans la rue,
les femmes viennent nous voir
et nous disent : "Moi aussi."
C'est ce que j'écris
avant que MeToo ne se déclenche,
et déjà, c'est "moi aussi".
Ca m'a frappée.
Ca a été pour moi
une révélation totale.
-C'est le côté positif
de ce que vous appelez
vous-même l'affaire Baupin.
Il y a un côté plus négatif,
c'est qu'un peu plus d'un an après,
vous quittez la politique.
Pourquoi ?
-Parce que ça a été trop dur.
-Qu'est-ce qui a été trop dur ?
-Ca a été d'une dureté inouïe,
ce qu'on s'est pris dans la tête...
Et puis le fait que cette parole
n'était pas acceptée.
Toutes, on a mis un pied à terre
parce qu'on n'y arrivait plus.
Je me suis arrêtée,
je me suis dit
que j'allais faire autrement
avancer les choses.
J'ai créé une association
qui a permis à plein de femmes
de prendre conscience
de plein de choses.
-Des groupes de paroles.
-Et qu'entre nous, sans sachant,
sans relation descendante,
juste entre nous à égalité.
Et au bout d'un moment,
je me suis dit :
"On peut pas non plus dire
aux femmes de parler et leur montrer
"qu'en fait,
parler remet tout en cause."
Il fallait que je revienne.
-Vous êtes revenue
en politique à partir de 2020,
mais j'ai l'impression
que votre vrai come-back,
c'est à l'été 2021.
Université d'été d'EELV,
vous vous portez candidate
à la primaire des écologistes.
Et là, c'est une nouvelle
Sandrine Rousseau
qui est apparue, avec un nouveau
logiciel politique,
l'écoféminisme.
Tout le monde connaît pas,
pouvez vous le définir
en quelques mots ?
-C'est de dire qu'à partir
du moment où vous estimez
que l'autre
n'est là qu'à votre service
et que vous pouvez l'utiliser,
le prendre et le jeter autant
qu'il est possible de le faire,
simplement par profit,
vous le faites des gens
comme vous le faites de la planète.
Comme le capitalisme
est fondé sur ça, c'est sur cela
qu'il faut nous battre
pour renverser les rapports...
-Vous mettez en parallèle
le capitalisme et le patriarcat.
-Tout à fait.
-J'en viens à ça.
L'écoféminisme n'offre pas
une vision très positive
de la masculinité.
Ca peut donner l'impression
que vous menez
un combat contre les hommes.
-C'est bien de le dire parce que
c'est précisément pas ça.
La société est divisée autour
de valeurs qui sont mises
du côté du masculin,
la valeur de conquête,
la valeur de domination,
d'être maître, possesseur,
mais c'est une construction sociale,
et en fait, les hommes, les humains,
ne sont pas ces critères-là.
Et il y a pas d'intérêt
à être conquérant, etc.
Il y a un intérêt à prendre soin,
à être à égalité
et à déconstruire
tous ces idéotypes.
-On en vient à cette fameuse phrase
sur votre compagnon :
"Vous vivez avec un homme
déconstruit."
On vous a raillée,
caricaturée sur cette phrase.
Mais est-ce que vous êtes prête,
dans le quotidien, à accorder
votre confiance à un homme
qui n'est pas déconstruit ?
-Quelqu'un qui n'a pas réfléchi
sur les rapports de domination
ne m'intéresse pas.
-Vous vous méfierez de lui ?
-Oui parce que je pense des impensés
qui mettent en danger les gens.
-Ce qui a changé
chez la Sandrine Rousseau
qu'on découvre en 2021,
c'est votre façon de faire
de la politique :
"Je pose les pieds
"dans le plat.
Sur le moment, c'est très violent,
"mais ça décante
et on avance un peu."
C'est comme ça que vous arrivez
à imposer vos thèmes
dans le débat ?
-Il y a eu des sondages d'opinion
suite à ce que j'avais porté,
notamment sur le barbecue,
sur la déconstruction,
sur les tâches ménagères,
et à chaque fois,
une majorité de Français
sont d'accord avec moi,
sur le droit à la paresse.
C'est ça qu'il faut mesurer.
On est dans un mouvement social
qui doit être représenté
dans le monde politique
et qui ne l'est pas suffisamment.
-Le 2 octobre 2022, dans "C à vous,"
vous avez mis les pieds dans le plat
et ça a été violent.
Vous avez accusé
le leader de votre propre parti,
Julien Bayou, d'avoir eu
"des comportements de nature
"à briser la santé morale
des femmes,"
celle de son ancienne
petite amie,
qui a commis
une tentative de suicide
après leur rupture
et qui s'est confiée à vous.
Il n'y a pas eu de plainte
contre Julien Bayou,
la victime ne l'a pas accusé
publiquement
et les faits ne semblent pas relever
d'une qualification pénale.
Vous assumez la violence
de votre démarche politique ?
-Ce qui me fascine,
c'est à quel point
il a été perçu comme violent
le fait que je dise juste
que j'ai reçu une femme
et l'état dans lequel je l'ai vue.
J'ai vu une femme,
quand je l'ai reçue,
qui n'allait vraiment pas bien.
Donc qu'on ose dise aujourd'hui
qu'une femme ne va pas bien,
que ça n'est pas normal
et que ça doit nous poser
une question sur les rapports
humains, et vérifier,
à tout le moins,
qu'il n'y ait pas d'autre situation
comme ça dans le parti,
a suscité un raz-de-marée,
et ça dit
que nous ne sommes pas prêts encore
à ouvrir ce champ
de ce que j'appelle
les violences psychologiques
et qui ont beaucoup de mal
à être qualifiées par la justice.
-La violence s'exerce aussi
contre vous.
Vous êtes régulièrement
menacée de mort, de viol,
notamment sur les réseaux sociaux,
mais pas seulement ?
Cette violence, vous la vivez
au quotidien ?
Dans la rue, ça peut vous arriver ?
-C'est pas tout le temps,
mais il y a des moments
où dans la rue,
ça devient compliqué,
notamment au moment
de l'affaire Bayou.
-Comment on vit avec ça ?
-Je vais pas vous dire
qu'on vit extrêmement bien.
Mais pour moi, ça fait partie
du combat politique
et des intimidations
qu'on essaie d'avoir
sur le combat que je porte.
Ca n'est pas négociable.
-On va passer à notre quiz,
si vous le voulez bien.
Je vais commencer
des phrases et ça va être
à vous de les compléter rapidement.
On y va.
-Etre une féministe
à l'Assemblée...
-C'est un combat de tous les jours.
-Vraiment compliqué ?
-Mazette ,oui !
J'ai été très surprise,
en arrivant dans l'hémicycle,
de voir à quel point
dès que je parlais,
il y avait des huées.
Mais on est où ?
On n'est pas à la fête
du masculinisme, on est
dans une Assemblée nationale,
et les députés ne se sont pas
toujours comportés correctement.
-A ceux qui me voient présidente
en 2027, je réponds...
-Qu'on est en 2023.
-Vous dites pas "pourquoi pas" ?
-On est en 2023,
et les cinq ans qui viennent,
c'est extrêmement important
pour la planète
et je me battrais
tous les jours.
On verra en 2027.
-Je dois reconnaître
qu'Emmanuel Macron...
qu'Emmanuel Macron
a une très haute opinion
de lui-même.
-Vous vous en sortez bien.
Vous n'arrivez pas à dire du bien
de lui.
-Vraiment, non.
-Rien de positif sur son bilan ?
-C'est un sujet, vraiment pas.
-Ce sera le mot de la fin.
Merci d'être venue.
-Merci.
SOUS-TITRAGE : RED BEE MEDIA
Générique
...